cette dernière décennie les professeurs
des écoles ont dit et répété leur
malaise dans l'actualité encore la
fronde des professeurs d'école
nous avons aujourd'hui une politique
éducative qui mène à l'impasse
le message est clair les problèmes sont
nombreux mais ils ne sont pas récents
commençons avec le salaire serait au
pays c'était en 1962 et maintenant la
même revendication un demi siècle plus
tard même si on a la garantie de
l'emploi
on aimerait mettre les salaires suis un
peu ce sentiment se confirme en chiffres
en 2020 un professeur des écoles
débutants touché 1700 57 euros nets
mensuels et 3300 5 euros après 30 ans de
carrière
maintenant voyons dans le temps le
salaire des professeurs des écoles à
augmenter certes mais cette hausse suit
la même évolution que le salaire médian
des français
conclusion cette augmentation de salaire
ne correspond pas à une meilleure
valorisation du métier aujourd'hui c'est
la même encore ou presse l'instituteur
du côté des conditions de travail
maintenant ben champoux sur le nombre
d'enfants par classe
il a globalement chuté jusqu en 2006
avec 22,6 enfants par classe avant de
repartir à la hausse et atteindre 23
élèves en moyenne en 2015 c'était pareil
en 2001 et en 1981 chez des difficultés
supplémentaires qu'on les mette
l'impossibilité dans certains cas de
juive tu es l'enfant qui se trouvait en
difficulté cela dit les derniers
chiffres de 2001 montrent que le nombre
moyen d'enfants par classe a diminué il
était 22,1 enfin pour compléter le
tableau il faut mentionner les heures de
préparation des cours hors classe aussi
importante
hier qu'aujourd'hui et d'innombrables
grèves des manifestations pour préserver
leurs conditions de travail
à défaut de les améliorer
[Musique]
enseigner c'est souvent présentée comme
une vocation une vocation celle à la
fois quoi j'ai toujours autant de
plaisir à retrouver mes élèves mais de
ce côté les chiffres montrent que le
sentiment n'est pas unanime en 2020 68,4
% des enseignants trouvé que leur
mission avait du sens c'est moins qu'en
2017 avec 77%
[Musique]